boils down to two huge forces that are
dramatically changing the world and will
do so even more over the next 20 30
years one force is the is a dark force
it's the population increase where we
had three billion people in nineteen
sixty five billion people in 1990 now we
had six billion or a little more and we
headed straight to 9 billion by 2050 so
between 1960 in 2050 we will have
tripled the world population on a planet
that's already extremely stressed in
terms of the environment arable land and
even social stressors so that's one huge
force that there is a massive force of
change and and that clearly plays a role
in my world view the other force is this
new world economy that is based on very
inexpensive telecommunications and
computer technologies which is a real
industrial revolution but unlike the
earlier and dust revolutions that had to
do with transforming energy or raw
materials this one goes very deep
because it transforms time and distance
and it makes knowledge the biggest
factor of production and that new
economy produces wonderful new things
new markets new ways of doing things
just sing of Bangalore in India
producing 15 billion dollars worth of
software services from 0 10 years ago
think of the ipod seems of many of these
wonderful new things but it's also a
very tough new economy where you have to
be agile you have to be good at
networking you have to be good at
constantly inventing new tricks and you
have to be very reliable and so some
countries and companies and individuals
do very well in that new economy some
fall by the wayside so it's a very most
positive and negative force but it's a
huge force and we've probably only seen
twenty percent of it this industrial
revolution based on telecoms and
computer technology still has eighty
percent to go and these two big forces
I think overwhelmed the capacity of the
human institutions we have to manage
them the human institutions being
nation-states the government's the
ministries the public agencies of
various kinds the international
organizations all that human system of
management is overwhelmed by these two
big forces and so I think we are seeing
the beginning of a governance gap sort
of inability to manage the forces which
we ourselves have unleashed